شكرا لك جمال واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
اذا تغطيتنا متواصله في اطار حصاد هذه
الليله والبدايه بالعناوين
تزايد التقديرات بارتفاع عدد القتلى مع
وجود الاف المفقودين جراء كارثه السيول في
الشرق الليبي واحصاء نحو خمسه الاف قتيل
جهود الانقاذ تتسارع خوفا من انتشار
الاوبئه وصور تظهر انهيار احياء باسرها
ودمارا في شبكه الطرق والجسور حول درنه
فرق الانقاذ في المغرب تكثف جهودها في قرى
معزوله قرب مركز الزلزال عمليات لفتح
مسالك جبليه مقطوعه لايصال المساعدات
للمناطق المنكوبه وعمليات الاغاثه تركز
على ايواء اللاجئين وعلاج المصابين
بعد يوم من اعلان اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
سبعه قتله في اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله
والقذائف الصاروخيه في مخيم عين الحلو
للاجئين الفلسطينيين جنوبيه لبنان
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا مع تغطيتنا لتطورات
السيول في درنه الليبيه
لا اله الا الله رب السماوات ورب الارض
ورب العرش الكريم
[موسيقى]
ذكرت وكاله الانباء الليبيه ان عدد القتلى
جراء السيول وصل الى خمسه الاف وثلاثمائه
بينما يقدر عدد المفقودين بالالاف من جهته
قال مسؤول في الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر ان نحو
عشرات الاف شخص هم في عداد المفقودين
واظهرت صور التقطت اليوم حجم الدمار الذي
خلفته السيول والفيضانات في مدينه درنه
خصوصا المناطق المتاخمه للوادي الذي يشق
المدينه والواجهه البحريه التي تاثرت
كثيرا بالسيول
معنى من طرابلس مراسل الجزيره احمد خليفه
احمد ما هي اخر المعلومات بشان سير اعمال
البحث والانقاذ وماذا عن المعلومات ايضا
التي افادت بامكانيه اخلاء المدينه تماما
قبل ذلك هناك معلومه او خبر وردنا منذ
لحظات فقط ان وهو نقلا عن مصدر حكومي اكد
لنا ان رئيس الحكومه عبد الحميد دبيبه
طالب النائب العام الليبي الصديقصور بفتح
تحقيق موسع وشامل في انهيار سدي درنه هذا
اخر تطور في قضيه درنه او في ازمه درنه
فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع على الارض حاليا كما
هي الاوضاع كما هي منذ ثلاثه ايام تقريبا
نحن اليوم سندخل في اليوم الرابع ربما بعد
ساعات
لليوم الرابع لانهيار سدي درنه وحدوس سيول
وفيضانات عارمه في المدينه اسفلت عن مقتل
الالاف وفقدان الالاف ايضا تحدثنا مع
مصادر حكوميه عفوا مصادر محليه من مدينه
تواصلنا معها عبر اقاربها من اهالي
الضحايا هنا في هذا العزاء الجماعي حيث
اقف الان في منطقه زاويه الدهماني
بالعاصمه طرابلس تواصلنا مع هذه المصادر
في مدينه درنه اكدوا لنا انه خلال الايام
الثلاثه
منذ انهيار السدين وحدود السيول وحتى
اليوم دفن في مقابر درنه اكثر من عشره
الاف ضحيه من ضحايا هذه السيول الى جانب
فقدان الالاف ايضا ايضا اكدت لنا هذه
المصادر ان الكهرباء على سبيل المثال رجعت
بشكل
تدريجي في الشق الشرقي من المدينه وكذلك
الاتصالات لكن اشق الغربي عفوا الشقه
الغربي الشرقي لكن الشق الغربي من المدينه
هو الذي يعاني اوضاعا الانسانيه ومعناه
انسانيه كبيره حسب وصفهم فما حدث في مدينه
درنه السيول جرفت ماءها كل شيء
ووسعت الهوه ما بين الشقين الغربي والشرقي
في مدينه درنه وبالتالي كل المساعدات التي
تاتي تاتي للشق الشرقي اما الشرق الغربي
فهناك معاناه انسانيه حيث يوجد حتى نقص في
امدادات المياه على اعتبار ان ما حدث ضرب
امدادات المياه والكهرباء بشكل كبير جدا
ايضا المصادر اكدت اكدت لنا ان عمليه
البحث هي الركيزه الاساسيه الان في مدينه
درنه لكن هذه العمليه تتم ببطء بعض الشيء
وليس هناك تسارع وهذا ما ادى حسب قول
المصادر
الى ان هناك تخوفات من انتشار اوبئه جراء
مرور ثلاثه ايام الان على وجود جثث كثيره
تحت الانقاذ وهذا قد يعني تحلل الجثث
وتعفنها مما قد يؤدي الى انتشار الاوبئه
لا سمح الله اشكرك حتى الساعه احمد خليفه
مراسلنا في طرابلس
منذرنا ينضم الينا صفوان المسوري عضو
المجلس الاعلى للدوله عن مدينه درنه مرحبا
بك سيد صفوان كيف تقيمون حتى الان عمليات
البحث والانقاذ الجاريه
سيد صفوان المسوري
للاسف يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع السيد
صفوان المسوري يفترض انه يحدثنا من درنه
وبطبيعه الحال يعني معلوم ان هناك مشكله
في التواصل
كانت كل الاتصالات وخدمه الانترنت قد
انقطعت وعادت قبل ساعات قليله الى المدينه
ولكن بشكل متقطع قد نعود اليه في سياق
الحصاد نتابع اذا لعبت الجغرافيا دورا في
تعظيم حجم الدمار في مدينه درنه شرقيه
ليبيا موقعها المنخفض عند شاطئ المتوسط
ووادي درنه الذي يقطعها والنهر الذي يمر
بها وغزاره الامطار شكلت عوامل اساسيه في
جرف احياء بكاملها الى البحر وبلغت مساحه
الدمار قرابه عشره كيلومترات مربعه في
المدينه التفاصيل نتابعها في التقرير
التالي
غلبت الجغرافيا كل الاحتمالات في ليبيا
وكما ان للزلزال من مركز باتت مدينه درنه
نقطه تركز الفاجعه
تقع دارنا على ضفاف واد كبير يعرف باسم
وادي درنه يتجاوز طوله 60 كيلومترا ومساحه
حوض التجميع فيه تبلغ
570 كيلومترا مربعا تقريبا
تقسم درنا الى مجموعه من الاحياء المنخفضه
التي تتشكل من مساحه واسعه تطل على البحر
المتوسط وابرزها وسط المدينه او المدينه
القديمه تتركز فيها اغلب المصارف
والمؤسسات الحكوميه والمقر الاداريه
والاسواق التجاريه وهي الاكثر تضررا من
السيول التي جرفت الابنيه ومنازل المدينه
القديمه والقت بها في البحر
زحفت اليها المياه بعد انهيار السدين في
درنه ووصل ارتفاع المياه ما بين سته امتار
وسبعه
حي الجبيله غرب المدينه جرفه السيد
بالكامل وحي المغار جنوب المدينه لحقه
الضرر بشكل واسع
وهناك احياء المدينه المرتفعه حي شيح
الغربيه حي الشيخ الشرقيه حي باب طبرق حي
الساحل الشرقي
تغير وجه المدينه بفعل العاصفه والطوفان
حيث تقدر المساحه التي تعرضت لتدمير
بقرابه عشره كيلومترات مربعه وبحسب خبراء
فان الضرر الهائل نتج عن عاملين اساسيين
كميه الامطار التي بلغت 200 مليمتر في يوم
واحد اي قرابه 200 لتر لكل متر مربع في
اقل من 24 ساعه
مقابل 200 مليمتر تسقط خلال عام كامل على
درنه هذه الكميات ادت الى تراكم 115 مليون
متر مكعب من المياه في وادي درنه
ولتقريب التقدير فان اي خزان منزلي للمياه
تبلغ سعته مترا مكعبا واحدا بمعنى ان
المياه التي حبست في الوادي تعادل 115
مليون خزان منزلي يضاف اليها قوه التدفق
الهائله والطم والحجاره التي سحبتها معها
ما رفع من قدره المياه التدميريه كما ان
انهيار السدين كان عاملا حاسما في تعظيم
قدره السيل على التدمير سد منصور يقع على
بعد 13 كيلومترا بسعه تخزينيه تقدر بنحو
ثلاثه وعشرين مليون مكعب سد البلاد الذي
يقع على بعد كيلو متر واحد من المدينه
بسعه تخزينيه تصل لمليون ونصف المليون متر
مكعب فقد السدان قدرتهما الاستيعابيه
وانفجر بشكل كامل
شيدت هذه السدود لحمايه المدينه من جريان
وادي درنه عام 2002 حذرت دراسه من ان سدود
درنه تشكل تهديدا محتملا رغم ذلك بقيت دون
اي صيانه
ليرتفع عدد الضحايا جراء هذه العوامل
مجتمعه الى الالاف بين قتيل ومفقود
من جديد ينضم الينا السيد صفوان المسوري
عضو المجلس الاعلى للدوله من درنه ينضم
الينا من مدينه درنه سيد صفوان هل تسمعنا
الان
مرحبا بك سالتك عن تقييمكم لعمليات البحث
والانقاذ الجاريه حتى الان في درنه
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه ان هناك جهود كبيره
جهود استثنائيه سواء كانت حكوميه
رسميه او عن طريق مؤسسات وافراد
بشكل غير رسمي عن طريق الجمعيات والاعمال
الخيريه لكن الحقيقه ان ان الفارسه يعني
انا زي ما تحدثت مع حضراتكم بالامس في
مستوى اخر تماما
لا يمكن للجهود المحليه ان تاتي اكلها في
هذا السبب من غير يعني من غير
هذه الجهود المحليه اثنان عمليات البحث عن
المفقودين والى
العالقين الامر
في هذه المرحله سيد صفوان من اجل
التسريع في عمليات البحث ومحاوله انقاذ من
يمكن انقاذه
الان الان يعني اليوم تحديدا
مثيره متسارعه لبعض المساعدات تصل من مصر
من تركيا من الجزائر من الحفر
لكن
المطلوب الان هو
الوصول السريع للفرق الفنيه والمجربه
والقادره على التعامل مع احداث مشابهه لما
حدث هناك فرق متخصصه تستطيع العمل
مع طبيعيه القاهره او مثل البراكين او
الزلازيل او ما شابه وبالتالي ما حدث في
زرنا هو امر او هو امر متابع لهذه الظواهر
فنحن نحتاج لا يوجد مثل هذه
المطلوبه تواجدها على الارض لا يوجد مثلها
في ليبيا مطلقا
لا يوجد اولا يعني ليبيا
بلد دائما بعيد عن
الزلازل وكذا اضافه الى ان البلد يعني منذ
13 سنه هو في حاله لاستقرار
وقلم الاولويات يختلف وبالتالي لم يتم
تنفيذ لا سبق ولا ولا اي مجموعات يعني
لها القدره على التعامل مع مثل ما حدث طيب
سيد صفوان
ماذا عن الازمات الاخرى المتعلقه بتك
دس من انتشار الاوبئه مشاكل المتعلقه
بفقدان مياه الشرب الغذاء الدواء هذه
المشاكل كيف يتم التعامل معها
يعني خليني خليني نقدم اجابه على على
النقطه الثانيه من السؤال هو ما يتعلق
بماء الترب والغذاء والدواء
والاسعافات الاوليه هذه
مجهودات محليه كبيره واعتقد الى جانب كبير
يمكن يعني
التغطيه ذلك لفتره معقوله جدا لكن الشق
الاول هو ما قصدته بطلب المساعده الثانيه
العازله من
كل ما يعني
طباله المده كل مكان الاثر اسوء من حيث
ستندات ونحن الان مازلنا
الروائع
عمليه
الامراض وانتشارها تتحول الى او قدر الله
فنقصتم تماما هو سرعه هذه الفرق الفنيه
محاوله لاستدراس ما يحدث
من
الارض خصوصا فيما يتعلق في عمليات انتشال
الجسم والمساعده في البحث على ما تبقى من
مطلوب في موضوع التعامل مع تكدس الجثث ما
المطلوب حاليا من اجل محاوله التعاطي مع
هذه الازمه
المطلوب المطلوب هو الام متخصصه وفرق
متخصصه لنقل هذه الجسم وتوفير اماكن لان
كل الاماكن دفن في محضرنا والتي يمكن
الذهاب اليها
في السيارات العاديه او بالامكانيات
البسيطه فامتلات على الاخر وبالتالي
محتاجين الى يعني امكانيات اضافيه ربما
حصل اماكن اخرى لدفن الجسامين الاهم من
هذا هو عمليه ازاله الرخام والبحث عن
مفقودين لان
عوائل واسر واهالي
المفقودين الذين لم يعرفوا لا مكان
ابنائهم
لا زالوا على قيد الحياه لا قدر الله
انتقلوا هذه هذا هو الامر هناك معلومات
سيد صفوان جرى تداولها عن ان هناك توجه
لدى سلطات الليبيه باخلاء مدينه درنه
بالكامل من الاحياء حتى يتم او يتسنى
للفرق البحث او استكمال عمليات البحث
والانقاذ ما حقيقه هذا التوجه وهل
بالامكان بالفعل تطبيقه في ظل وضع الطرق
والبنى التحتيه عموما
الحقيقه منذ اليوم منذ اليوم بدات بمحاوله
يعني
اغلاق
المنطقه المصابه اللي هي
بحدود الاطلاق الكيلومتر مربع تقريبا
ومنع وصول الناس اليها او على الاقل
وصولهم بشكل كبير حتى
تسهل عمليه البحث لكن اخلاء الذين بالكامل
هذا امر غير مطروح يعني لان الجزء المدمر
من المدينه من حيث المساحه هو يفسد ربما
اقل من ربع المدينه يعني ربما هو
اللاعبين
المساحه الاجماليه المدينه
[موسيقى]
كلها يعني والمغار كذلك
بفضل الله الحمد لله هي مناطق امنه ولم
تتضرر
جدا خطوط الامطار ولم يطالها الضرر ايضا
وبالتالي هي اماكن يعني هائله للسكان
وتحتاج فقط الى عمليات تنظيف واعاده
الكهربائي بعوده الحياه فيها مره اخرى
رئيس المجلس الرئاسي وجه قبل قليل النائب
العام بفتح تحقيق موسع وشامل في انهيار
السدين اللذين الى هذا الفيضان الهائل في
دارنا كيف وجدتم هذه الخطوه
خطوه خطوه خطوه جيده
الحقيقه لان بصراحه
عمرهما اكثر من اربعين عام وبالتالي دون
ان هما بحاجه الى صيانه وربما ان لم نقل
توسعه وتطوير
وبالتالي يعني هناك لا شك فيه تقدير في
حاله السردين وتقدير
لك كميه الامطار التي فيها الضغط على زرنا
في ذلك اليوم المشؤوم وبالتالي يعني هناك
مسؤوليه تقع على جهه ماء هذا لا ينفي طبعا
ان ان نسبه المياه كانت استثنائيه وغير
مسبوقه
ويعني ربما لاول مره المنصه لكن هذا لا
ينفي وجود مسؤوليه ما خصوصا في التوقع
مبكر
هذه هذه الامطار اعاده بطولها وبالتالي
ربما كان في امكانيه لتجاوز شكرا جزيلا لك
صفوان المسوري عضو المجلس الاعلى للدوله
عن مدينه درنه حدثتنا من داخل درنا
للتعرف على ابرز مراحل عمليات الانقاذ في
مرحله ما بعد الفيضانات نتابع التقرير
التالي
في مرحله ما بعد الفيضانات المدمره فان
الخطوه الاولى وكما هي الحال بالتعامل مع
مختلف انواع الكوارث الطبيعيه تكون بالبحث
عن الناجين واجلاء العالقين والمحاصرين في
المناطق الخطره ويجب ان تضم فرق الانقاذ
افرادا المدربين ومجهزين بالمعدات اللازمه
مثل القوارب ومعدات الصوت والكلاب المدربه
الخطوه الثانيه تكون بتقديم رعايه الطبيه
للمصابين وتقديم المساعدات الاساسيه من
ماكل ومشرب وماوى للمتضررين والمشردين من
الفيضانات ويجب الحذر خلال هذه المرحله من
حصول انزلاقات طينيه او انجرافات للتربه
في المناطق التي اجتاحتها السيول تستمر
هذه المرحله ما بين ثلاثه ايام الى اسبوع
وربما اكثر فالامر يعتمد على حجم الفيضان
ومساحه المناطق المتضرره ومدى توفر
الموارد البشريه معدات اللازمه لفرق البحث
والانقاذ وقدرتهم على التنقل من منطقه
لاخرى قياسا على مستوى الضرر الذي لحق
بالبنيه التحتيه المرحله الثانيه تبدا
بالتركيز على انتشال جثامين الضحايا
ودفنها خصوصا في ظل المخاطر الناتجه عن
تحلل الجثث وتلويثها لمصادر المياه الامر
الذي يزيد من خطر انتشار الامراض المعديه
مثل الكوليرا والتفويد كما يجب البدء
بمعالجه مظاهر التلوث البيئي الذي تحدثه
الفيضانات على المناطق المتضرره لاسيما في
حال تسببت بانهيار شبكات الصرف الصحي
وانتشار المستنقعات وتجمعات المياه
الملوثه والفضلات اذ يمكن ان يتسبب التاخر
في مواجهه ذلك بحصول كارثه طبيه وانتشار
الاوبئه وتعتمد مده هذه المرحله على حجم
الكارثه ونطاقها الجغرافي والامكانات
المتاحه لفرق الاغاثه الانقاذ اما المرحله
الثالثه مرحله التعافي فتبدا بالعمل على
تجهيز اماكن اقامه دائمه لعائلات المنكوبه
واعاده تاهيل البنيه التحتيه من طرق
وشبكات صرف صحي وكهرباء وازاله الانقاض
ومخلفات الفيضان وتختتم هذه المرحله
باعاده انشاء السدود وتعزيز البنيه
التحتيه المجاوره للانهار والاوديه واتخاذ
الاجراءات اللازمه للحقولي دون حصول كوارث
مستقبليه او التقليل من اثارها على الاقل
[موسيقى]
قال الناطق باسم المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
محمد ابو نجيله للجزيره ان ثلاثين الف شخص
على الاقل شردوا في مدينه درنه بسبب
الفيضانات كما وصل عدد النازحين جراء
السيول في البيضاء الى ثلاثه الاف شخص وفي
بنغازي الى 410 عائلات وذكرت المنظمه في
بيان ان عدد النازحين بلغ سته الاف وخمسه
وثمانين شخصا
نحن في المنظمه الدوليه للهجره ارسلنا
اليوم بتقرير فيه بيانات كما كما تفضلتم
بان 30 الف شخص شردوا ونزحوا من منازلهم
في مدينه درنا هناك ايضا العديد من
الاشخاص في مدن اخرى نزحوا مثل مدينه
البياضه والتي شهدت ثلاثه الاف شخص نجحوا
هناك في مدينه بنغازي سجلنا نحن في
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره 410 عائلات ايضا
نجحوا من
يعني المدينه فهناك حاجه كبيره والكارثه
عظيمه ولا زلنا نقوم باحصاء
يعني الاضرار الناجمه عن تلك الكارثه
من طرابلس ينضم الينا اسامه علي المتحدث
باسم جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ الذي مرحبا بك
سيد اسامه ما نوع الصعوبات التي تواجه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ حاليا في دارنا
الموضوع تجاوز مرحله البحث عن صعوبات
وماذا وجد من صعوبات في الصعوبات النوويه
قد تم اجتيازها بفضل ما تم انجازه على
الارض مثلا الطرق المتقطعه تم عمل تحويلات
في الطريق مثلا المناطق الغارقه الحمد لله
يعني في كثير الان من الفرق اللي عملت على
شفط المياه من المناطق الغارقه غير ذلك
الطرق اللي كانت مسدوده يعني التحويلات
حلت المشاكل نوعا ما في عمليه التنقل في
المنطقه الشرقيه بالكامل ليس درنه فحسب
فنحن نتحدث عن منطقه شرقيه امتدادها من
بنغازي نمتد الى عند مدينه البيضه هذه هي
مركز الكوارث وبعد ذلك ننطلق الى ناحيه
سوسه هناك ايضا كارثه اخرى في مدينه سوسه
فلذلك نحن اجتزنا مرحله
البحث عن حلول المعوقات بالطريقه
التقليديه وعليك ان تجتاز هذا الموضوع
وتبتكر حلا لنفسك وكيف ابتكرتم الفنون
لنفسكم ما نوع الحلول التي قمتم
لنفسنا على الاقل يعني نحن كفرق جهاز
اسعاف وطوارئ انطلقنا من لدعم فروع جهاز
اسعاف الطوارئ في منطقه في منطقتنا
الشرقيه في شرق الوطن
جل الفروع في المنطقه الغربيه انطلقت سواء
من المنطقه من الساحل الغربي بالكامل من
الجبل الغربي بالكامل من الجنوب الغربي
بالكامل من الجنوب الاوسط بالكامل من
الجنوب الشرقي بالكامل من المنطقه الوسطى
بالكامل قدموا الدعم باكثر من اربعين
سياره اسعاف ابتكار الحل هو متطوعي سيارات
الاسعاف الخاصه اللي ترفع لهم القبعه
لدعمهم جهاز اسعاف الطوارئ بتقديمهم 80
سياره اسعاف
توجهت ايضا
لدعم فرق جهاز اسعاف والطوارئ كل الانظار
الان لخطوه كل الانظار لخطوه اخرى الا وهي
الانتهاء من عمليات البحث ونقول لم يعد
هناك مفقودين ولم يعد هناك اي وفيات
وننتظر ان نرى بؤره امل
من الراس المطروح نتحدث عن اعداد هائله من
الضحايا بين القتلى وبين المفقودين في هذه
المرحله ما هي فرص العثور على ناجين
جيد فرص العثور على ناجيين دائما تكون
ضئيله كلما امتد الوقت نحن الان نشارف على
72 ساعه من سيل وليس زلزال وضعي هذه بين
قوسين عندما نتحدث عن السيول فانت تتحدثين
عن طين وطمي وحجاره ومخلفات واشجار
التجريفها المياه وتذهب فجرفت بيوت
باكملها الى عمق البحر فكلما امتد الوقت
اصبحت كل دقيقه تعني فقدان ارواح فالاثنين
وسبعين ساعه هذه تقلص من وجود ناجين صراحه
في المناطق المنكوبه هذا للامانه ما حدث
اليوم اثبت ذلك صباح اليوم بدا البحر يخرج
ما في جعبته من ضحايا لهذه الفاجعه في
ليبيا فاستقبلت مدينه البيضاء على سبيل
المثال عند ساعات الصباح الاولى اليوم 50
جثثمانا من عمق البحر استقبلت الساحل
الاخضر حوالي عشرين جثمانا من البحر وما
زالت وما زال البحر يخرج ما في جعب ته
ناهيك عن المناطق الاخرى التي
دفن فيها للاسف الشديد الضحايا بالطين
وبالطمي وبالركام فوقا عن هذا
الفاجعه اكبر مما تطرح حاليا ليست درنه
فقط فدرنا نالت نصيب الاسد من الفاجعه
ولكن هناك مدن اخرى بجوار درنه ايضا تعاني
وتستغيث
شكرا لك اسامه علي المتحدث باسم جهاز
الاسعاف والطوارئ الليبي ضيفنا من طرابلس
شكرا لك
الى المغرب والمشهد في ختام اليوم مع
اقتراب الزلزال من اكمال يومه الخامس
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب حيث تواصلوا فرق الانقاذ
جهودها للوصول الى احياء تحت الركام في
المناطق المتضرره من زلزال الجمعه الماضي
كما تستمر العمليات الراميه لفتح الطرق
الجبليه المؤديه الى القرى النائيه وسط
مخاوف من انهيارات صخريه جديده وتركز فرق
الانقاذ بل تركز فرق الانقاذ جهودها
لانقاذ واجلاء الجرحى وتكفل بالمتضررين
الذين فقدوا الماوى وقد افادت وزاره
الداخليه بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى
والمصابين الى 56747
لتفاصيل اكثر نتحول الى عثمان اي فرح في
المغرب وجوله مع مراسلين على الارض هناك
عثمان
ارتداديه اليوم
ومعنى من مراكش عمر الحاج ومن امتحناه
معنا المختار العلاوي سابدا بك يا ميساء
ميساء الفطناسي انت في داخل المدينه
شاهدتي كيف تاثر ريف ام زميز ولكن كيف
تاثرت المدينه وحدثينا عن الهزه ارتداديه
او الهزتين اليوم كنت بالقرب من المكان
وكان الامر ربما خطيرا نوعا ما بالنسبه
للمتواجدين في المكان وكنت احد المتواجدين
هناك
نعم عثمان بالفعل الوضع اليوم في امزميز
كان صعبا مع هذين الهزتين
الارتداديتين في التي شعر بها كل سكان
المدينه وايضا المنطقه الريفيه التابعه
لمنطقه امزميز كنا شاهدين على الهزه
الارتداديه الاولى عندما كان اعوان
الانقاذ وفرق الانقاذ المحليه والاجنبيه
هناك تقوم بعمليات البحث عن ناجين وسط
الركاب الذي كان في منطقه
بتزميز واثناء عمليات البحث
هذا ارتداديه وكان هناك ايضا سقوط صخره
كبيره اثناء عمليه الانقاذ كان المشهد
يعني حاله كبيره من الرعب والخوف هناك
ولكن الحمد لله لم تكن اضرار ماديه ما عدا
بعض الاصابات الطفيفه هناك نتحدث عن اثار
الزلزال كما وجدنا او عاينا صعوباتها في
الارياف ايضا في المناطق الحضريه هنا في
المدن تبدو وتتكشف مشاكل واثار الزلزال
بشكل كبير خصوصا مع حلول الظلام وفي الليل
حيث تغيب الاناره وحيث الناس الذين خرجوا
من منازلهم الى الخيام كما ان نشاهد هنا
يقضون اوقاتهم بشكل صعب خصوصا وان درجات
الحراره تنخفض بشكل كبير ونحن نشعر بالبرد
حاليا فما بالك هؤلاء الذين لا تتوفر
لديهم في اغلب الاوقات وسائل التدفئه
وايضا الاغطيه وغيرها رغم ذلك هناك
مجهودات في الطرف المقابل من قبل الجمعيات
الاهليه من قبل الاطراف المدنيه ومن قبل
ايضا الاطراف الحكوميه لتجاوز هذه المصاعب
ولمديد المساعده للجميع وذلك نعينه بشكل
كبير وواضح حيث ان الطرق على امتداد اليوم
تكتظ بالسيارات سواء كانت سيارات تابعه
لجمعيات او لسيارات لاشخاص يقومون بمبادره
فرديه او لسيارات حكوميه تحاول ان توصل
المساعدات للجميع من اجل تجاوز هذه
المشاكل المتعلقه بالظروف اليوميه للفرين
من منازلهم بسبب الزلزال
نعم
نعم ميساء وربما لم تكوني تودين الحديث عن
الجانب الشخصي ولكن انت كنت قريبه
من حيث حدث انهيار ومصخري بسيط الحمد لله
على سلامه الطاقم هناك نرجو من الجميع
طبعا نتوكل حذر الامر معقد وليس سهلا شكرا
لك وسننتقل الى المختار العلاوي انت في
تحناوت وهناك تشكلت مجتمعات صغيره اصبحت
هناك حياه معينه لها كيف تعيش هذه
المجتمعات الصغيره التي تشكلت في هذه
الظروف الصعبه في تحمناوت مع الاستعداد
ايضا لاي تقلبات محتمله في المناخ المختار
نعم بالفعل عثمان اصبح بائع الخضار بين
الخيام اصبح الناس يصلون صلواتهم في
العراء لان المساجد ايضا تضررت من الزلزال
وهناك اشكال مختلفه سنتعرف على بعض من هذه
الاشكال هنا نرى ان الناس بدات تقوم
بتدعيم القيم التي قامت باقامتها هناك
خيام وزعتها سلطات هناك خيم اخامها
الاهالي الان تم تدعيمها بهذه الاغطيه
البلاستيكيه تحسبا
لتساقطات مطريه ساره اهلا بك ساره لماذا
الان الاطيه بلاستيكيه
البلاستيكيه
لفصل الشتاء هلا فصل الامطار
لانه ليس لدينا خيم اولا ونحن نعاني بشده
هنا لان منازلنا كلها انشقت ونحن على
العراء عملنا هذه الاشياء لكي نكون محميين
من البرد والشتاء
تقوم بهذه الاسره الحاج مصطفى السلام
عليكم عليكم السلام ورحمه الله اذن من
البيت الى الخيمه من البيت الى الخيمه
وقدر الله جابوا لنا الله مرحبا به اللي
جابها الله مرحبا بها وهذا الشيء مكتوب
والانسان يتوب شويه ويعرف الله
وهذه هي هذه هي الحياه هي هذه وما عندنا
ما نقولوا لجبل الله مرحبا بها احنا ماشي
احنا
البشر خصنا
نتوبوا الله ونعرفوا بانه
هذا هو جانب من المشهد نشاهد ايضا مجموعه
من الخيام حيث قام الاهالي
بتدريجيا خلال ساعات هذا اليوم باضافه هذه
الاغطيه البلاستيكيه هناك اقبال من حيث
البيع والشراء على شراء هذه الاغطيه
البلاستيكيه تحسبا لايه تحولات مناخيه او
امطار وما الى ذلك
التعليم على سبيل المثال متوقف لحد اللحظه
بالنظر الى الوضعيه وضعيه المدارس هي ايضا
تضررت كما هو الحال تضرر تدرب بقيه
المنازل والمؤسسات الاخرى معظم المؤسسات
في هذه المناطق كما هو حال المنازل
المدنيه الكل تضررا من الزلزال اما
بانهيارات او بانهيارات
جزئيه عثمان
نعم المختار وعمر انت في مراكش ومراكش هي
مركز لانطلاق كثير من المساعدات في الوقت
الذي فتحت فيه بعض الطرق وتاتي فيه ايضا
قوافل المساعدات كثيره من المناطق
المختلفه من التراب المغربي
هذا صحيح عثمان هي المحطه الاولى المدينه
عاصمه الولايه انطلاقا الى المناطق التي
تضررت وما تزال ما زلنا كما شهدنا اليوم
الكثير من الحافلات قادمه من مناطق مختلفه
حتى من اقصى شمال البلاد اريد فقط ان اعرج
بسرعه على هذا المنظر خلفي عثمان ما يبدو
ان الهزات الارتداديه انعشت حركه التوجه
باتجاه الحدائق والمنتزهات ونصب خيام على
عجل هنا وسط المدينه هؤلاء منهم من بقي في
هذه المنطقه منذ بدايه الزلزال ومنهم من
كما ذكرت حرضته هل هزه الارتداديه اليوم
والتي وين لم يشعر بها في مراكش ولكن علم
بخبرها اثر البقاء في الخارج الحقيقه
التغيير الذي طرا على طباع التغيير الذي
طرا على المغ هنا في هذه المنطقه ترى ايضا
على طبيعتي على على طبيعتهم الج على
الجغرافيه المكان اليوم عندما كنا نتجول
مع فرق الانقاذ في في اقليمه شيشاوه
شاهدنا تفجر ينابيع للمياه صغير مياه صغير
حقيقه عين صغيره كانت قد كما قال السكان
انفجرت مره اخرى
بالقرب من حيث حطت خيامهم بعد ان نهار
الدوار او انهارت بيوت الضيعه التي كانوا
يعيشون فيها الاهالي قالوا لنا ان هذه
العين جفت منذ سنوات طويله مجراها كان
باقيا في تلك المنطقه ولكنه عاود مره اخرى
بعد وقوع الاجهزه عن التغيير في الطباع
الخوف والتوتر والقلق وايضا تغيير على
الجغرافيا في تلك المنطقه لو كان بعجال
الحديث عن الجهود الاغاثيه الامر يوما بعد
يوم عثمان يبدو اكثر تنظيما مما سبق لم
تعد لم يعد كل الافراد يتوجه لوحدها او
بسيارته الى تلك المنطقه السلطات لا تمنع
هؤلاء ولكن تنصحهم
تنصحهم لكي يبقوا ما احضروهم من مساعدات
في مراكز التخزين ليتم توزيعها بعد ذلك من
قبل مختصين من قبل المتطوعين
نعم وفي انتظار الوقت المناسب حسب ما تراه
السلطات للعوده الى المنازل او ايجاد مئوي
مؤقته وهذا يتم الان ولكن يبدو انه سياخذ
وقتا مع العدد الكبير جدا من المتضررين
شكرا لك من مراكش عمر الحاجه من نزميز
شكرا لك مساء الفطناسي لمختار العلاوي في
تحناوت في اقليم الحوز شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا
ولكل شبكه مراسلين في هذه التغطيه الخاصه
لتداعيات الزلزال من المغرب
[موسيقى]
الى جنوب لبنان حيث افادت مصادر طبيه
فلسطينيه بسقوط سبعه قتلى واربعه وعشرين
جريحا في اشتباكات بمخيم عين الحلو
للاجئين الفلسطينيين اليوم بين عناصر من
حركه فتح ومجموعه تطلق على نفسها اسم
الشباب المسلم ورجع تجدد الاشتباكات بعد
هدوء نسبيا شهده المخيم خلال الساعات
الماضيه تخللته بعض الحروق بين الحين
والاخر كما ياتي بعد اتفاق بين قيادتي
حركتي فتح وحماس في بيروت على المضي قدما
بقرار هيئه العمل الفلسطيني المشترك
بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار في المخيم
وتسليم المتهمين بغتيال قائد قوات الامن
الوطني الفلسطيني ابو اشرف العرموشي نهايه
يوليو الماضي الى السلطات اللبنانيه
معنى من محيط مخيم عين الحلوه في صيدا
مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم مرحبا بك
مازن كيف يتطور الموقف
[موسيقى]
متقطعه بين الحين والاخر تجتد كنت اقول
بان الكل المفاوضات التي حصلت لا سيما
الاجتماع الذي شهدته السفاره الفلسطينيه
فجر اليوم الماضي وترجم من خلال بيان
مشترك من فتح وحماس اكد تثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار والعمل على حذف المسلحين على
التسليم المتهمين باغتيال قائد الامن
الوطني الفلسطينيه ابو اشرف العلموشي كل
هذه الاتفاقات
ذهبت ادراج الرياح من خلال الاشتباكات
المتواصله بطبيعه الحال كل الطرف يتهم
الاخر بانه يقوم بخرق اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار وهذه الاتفاقات لم تصمد طيله الفتره
الماضيه كان هنالك عده محاولات محاولات
قامه بها الجيش اللبناني من خلال اجتماعات
عقدتها اداره المخابرات هنا في مدينه صيدا
اعقل ذلك اجتماع لدى الامن العام اللبناني
للفصائل الفلسطينيه ومشاورات سواء مع رئيس
البرلمان نبيه بري او حتى حكومه تصنيف
الاعمال نجيب نقاطي ولكن كل هذه الاتفاقات
وكل هذه
الصيغ التي تم التوصل اليها لم يتم
احترامها من الاطراف المتقاتله والان
عمليا هنالك نجوح لمئات العائلات خارج
مخيم عين الحلوه نتيجه كل هذه التطورات
الداميه التي كانت قد بدات في نهايه شهر
يوليو وعمليا ما يحصل اننا امام اكثر من
27 قتيلا بالاضافه الى عشرات الجرحى
الحديث عن اكثر من 200 جنيه طيله هذه
الفتره ولا شيء حتى الان ينبئ ال سي بانه
يمكن الحديث عن وقف لاطلاق النار قريب او
اليه واضحه لترجمه كل الاتفاقات بين
الاطراف الفلسطينيه المتعدده للتوصل الى
وقف ناجز لاطلاق النار يوقف هذه المعارك
المستمره منذ مطلع سبتمبر وكانت جولتها
الاولى قد بدات في نهايه يوليو الماضي
بطبيعه الحال نتابع معك كل جديد في هذا
الاطار حتى الساعه نشكرك مدير مكتب
الجزيره في بيروت مازن ابراهيم حدثنا من
محيط مخيم عين الحلوه في مدينه صيدا جنوب
لبنان قالت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان خمسه
فلسطينيين استشهدوا واصيب تسعه عشر جراء
انفجار خلال مسيره قرب الحدود شرق مدينه
غزه ووصفت المصادر الطبيه جراحه عدد من
المصابين بالحرجه من جانبها نعت اللجنه
الوطنيه العليا للحركات الاسيره الشهداء
الذين كانوا يشاركون في فعاليات الشباب
السائر دعما للاسرى في سجون الاحتلال وفي
وقت سابق اصيب خمسه فلسطينيين جراء اطلاق
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه النار وقنابل
الغاز عليهم خلال مشاركتهم في فعاليات دعت
اليها الفصائل الفلسطينيه في ذكرى انسحاب
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من قطاع غزه ومرور 30
عاما على اتفاقيه اوسلو
من غزه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط هشام ما ملابسات ما حدث
ما حدث هو انفجار وقع اثناء تجمع عدد من
الشبان قرب السياج الفاصل شرق مدينه غزه
وما جرى يمكن وصفه بانه انفجار عرضي خلال
فعاليات اقيمت على الحدود شرق مدينه غزه
هذه الفعاليات دعت لها فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حيث اقيم في البدايه مهرجان
جماهير تخلله كلمه للفصائل الفلسطينيه
والغرفه المشتركه للاجنحه العسكريه في
ذكرى الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من قطاع غزه
وبعد انتهاء هذا المهرجان توجه المشاركون
والشباب الثائر كما يطلق عليهم هنا في غزه
توجهوا الى الحدود حيث ينتشر الجيش
الاسرائيلي بكثافه في تلك المنطقه ودارت
اشتباكات بين هؤلاء الشبان وجنود الاحتلال
استمرت نحو ساعه من الزمن واطلق الجيش
الاسرائيلي النار وقنابل الغاز على
المتظاهرين واصيب عدد منهم بالاختناق عند
مغيب الشمس تبدا فعاليات الارباك الليلي
كما يطلق عليها هنا في غزه فعاليات ينفذها
شبان ثائرون يشغلون جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المنتشره قواته على الحدود
الشرقيه من رفح جنوبا وحتى بيت حانون
شمالا وتحدث عمليات كر وفر بين هؤلاء
الشبان وجنود الاحتلال يشعل الشبان
الاطارات المطاطيه وهتفوا دعما للاسرى
وهتفوا هتافات تضامن مع الضفه الغربيه
وردده هتافات غاضبه على الاعتداءات
المتكرره للمسجد الاقصى وخلال هذه
الفعاليات وكما قالت لجنه متابعه القوى
الوطنيه والاسلاميه حدث انفجار عرضي لعبوه
تستخدم في نشاط الارباك الليلي اذا هو حدث
جانبي حدث عرضي لهذه العبوه التي انفجرت
فيها هؤلاء الشبان انفجرت اثناء تجمع
الشبان قربى السياج الفاصل وهذا ربما يفسر
العدد الكبير من الشهداء والمصابين وبعض
هذه الاصابات بحسب المصادر الطبيه وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه وصفت بالخطيره وهذا ربما
يرجح ارتفاع عدد الشهداء بسبب هذه
الاصابات الخطيره التي نقلت جميعها الى
مجمع الشفاء الطبي وهناك اجريت عمليات
جراحيه لعدد من هؤلاء الشبان وسيجري غدا
تشييع الشهداء الى مثواهم الاخير الجميع
هنا فصائليا شعبيا هناك حاله من الغضب
جراء هذه
جرائها العدد الكبير من الشهداء والجميع
يحمل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المسؤوليه وتؤكد
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان كل قطره دم
فلسطينيه تسقط خلال مسيره الدفاع عن
المسجد الاقصى عن مدينه القدس وللتضامن
ايضا مع الاسرى وضد الحصار الاسرائيلي
المفروض على قطاع غزه فان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هو من يتحمل فقط مسؤوليتها
شكرا لك من غزه مراسلنا هشام زقوط
[موسيقى]
قال فولك مبعوث الامين العام للامم
المتحده الى السودان انه طلب من الامين
العام للمنظمه الدوليه اعفائه من منصبه في
هذه الاثناء نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
عن مصدر طبي سوداني ان اربعين شخصا قتلوا
في غاره جويه استهدفت سوقين شعبيين وعده
احياء في مدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب
دارفور غربيه السودان
ليس امام الامين العام المتحده الا
الاستجابه لطلب السودان وتغيير هذا
المبعوث لن يتعامل معه انا انا لو كنت
مكان السيد فلتر سوف اقدم استقلت وقد كان
لكن وهو يعلن تنحيه عن منصبه اثر فولكر
رسم المشهد السوداني كما بداله
ليس هناك شك في المسؤول عن ما يجري في
كثير من الاحيان ينفذ القصف الجوي
العشوائي من قبل اولئك الذين لديهم قوه
جويه وهي القوات المسلحه السودانيه تحدث
معظم اعمال العنف الجنسي والنهب والقتل
فالمناطق التي تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم
السريع يقوم كلا الجانبين بالاعتقال
التعسفي والاحتجاز وحتى تعذيب المدنيين
وهناك تقارير عن عمليات قتل خارج نطاق
القضاء ذاك تقرير مهمه انتهت ولعلها طوت
معها ازمه الموفه الاممي الخاص مع سلطات
الخرطوم التي صنفته شخصا غير مرغوب فيه
ايا يكون الامر فان الدبلوماسيه الالماني
ما زال يخشى من تحول نزاع السودان كما
يقول الى حرب اهليه
هل الى ذلك تسير الاحداث بالبلاد حقه
الواضح من تطورات الصراع المسلح انه لا
يفتا يحتدم في مدن العاصمه القوميه الثلاث
ولا تخف معه حده موجات الاقتتال الممتده
الى اقليم دارفور بغربي البلاد
مشاهد الحرب هنا وهناك تفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه لملايين هم خارجه حسابات
الاطراف المتقاتله
ليست حسابات الحروب كلها عسكريه فهذا قائد
الجيش ورئيس مجلس السياده السوداني يكثف
جولاته الخارجيه
الى مركز لحكمه ونشاطه
منها انطلق عبد الفتاح البرهان الى
القاهره فاجبا فاسمر فالدوحه ثم اخيرا
انقره التي سبق وابدت استعدادها لاستضافه
مفاوضات شامله لانهاء الصراع الدائري في
السودان لكن ايا من طرفي الصراع هناك لم
يرد بعد بشكل رسمي على العرض التركي
من نيويورك ينضموا الينا بكر الجاك المدني
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي السوداني مرحبا
بك سيد بكري اي معانى باعتقادك تنطوي
عليها هذه الخطوه التي اقدم عليها اليوم
فولك بالطلب باعفائه من مهامه
مساء الخير عليك السيده ولمشاهديك اينما
كانوا اعتقد هي خطوه متوقعه ليس هنالك ما
يفادي في هذا الاستقاله وزاره لعده اسباب
طبعا من ناحيه عمليه اصبح السيد غير قادر
على القيام بمهمته نتيجه تعقيدات الجمر
التي وضعتها
الحكومه السودانيه التي تدعي ان
لا يقف موقف الحياد في هذا الصراع طبعا
هذه المساله يمكن الاخذ والرد فيها فلم
يعد وقت القيامه مهمته هذه واحده هنالك
عوامل اخرى تتعلق بعدم الاستجابه الامم
المتحده ما زالت تطالب بالغوث الانسان
للشعب السوداني والمعدل الاستجابه لا
يتجاوز الا 26% وهذا يؤكد انه لم يعد
بالكاد قادرا على القيام بمهمته حتى التي
خارج مساحه البلاد فيبدو ان السيد فوكر
نعم يبدو انه
يبدو انه قد وصل الى قناعتها مع انه لم
يعد بقدرته للقيام بمهامته سواء في
الداخله وفي الخارج ولكن كيف وجدت ايضا
الحديث الذي
ادلى به ويخرج به من هذه المهمه
بتوجيه الانتقاد للطرفين في تحمل مسؤوليه
ما حدث في السودان والوقوف وراء جرائم حرب
حدثت
بانه قال مثل هذا القول في هذا المحفل في
مجلس الامن لاننا كمراقبين وكمتابعين زرنا
نقول هذا الكلام منذ بدايه الانطلاق الحرب
ليس هنالك شك في عند القوات المسلحه تقوم
بالقصف العشوائي الغير منظم مستهدفه
المدنيين لا اقول عن قصد ولكن لسبب متعلق
بالن قوات الدعم السريعه اثرت ان تخوض
المعارك من بيوت المواطنين واثرت ان تتخذ
من المواطنين المدنيين كدر دروع بشريه هذه
معركه اصبح المدنيون في فيها عباره عن
ضحيه بين الفصيلين المتقاتلين وانت تتحدث
الينا سيد بكر الجاكي المدني اريد ان انوه
الى هذا الخبر او الخبر العاجل الذي ظهر
الذي يظهر على شاشتنا نقلا عن البعثه
الامميه في السودان تتحدث عن تلقيها
تقارير موثوقه عن وجود ما لا يقل عن 13
مقبره جماعيه في الجنينه ومحيطها وتقول ان
المقابر هي نتيجه هجمات قوات الدعم السريع
وميليشيات عربيه على مدنيين معظمهم من
المساليد كيف يمكن التعليق على هذه
المستجدات سيد بكري
هذا هذا امر مؤسف
واجدني في غايه الاسى لما يحدث لكنني لست
متفاديا اعتقد حينما ينجلي امر هذه الحرب
في البلاد سنجد ان هنالك العديد من
المقابر الجماعيه وليس في الجنينه وحدها
ستكون هنالك مقابر جماعيه في الخرطوم
سيكون هنالك مقابل جماعيه اينما كان هنالك
قتال الحذر حرب خرجت على السيطره وهنالك
قوات من الميليشيات العربيه التي تتدثر
وتحتمي بقوات الدعم السريع وتقوم بهذه
المعارك وتقوم بهذا القتل العشوائي انا في
تقدير ربما سنكتشف ان هنالك العديد من
المقابر الجماعيه التي لم يتوصل اليها
الخبراء بعد لست متفاجا ولكنني في غايه
الحزن والاسى لمقاله في هذا البلاد
وتاسف جدا لصمت المجتمع الدولي وعدم
قابليته للحركه وعدم الضغط على الطرفين
شكرا جزيلا لك بكر الجاكي المدني
الاكاديمي والم حلل السياسي السوداني
ضيفنا من نيويورك
غادر الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون
روسيا بعد زياره التقى خلالها الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين في اقصى شرق البلاد حيث
تجولا في قاعده فوستوشيني احدث موقع روسي
لاطلاق الصواريخ الفضائيه وبينما اكد كيم
ان بلاده ستضع العلاقات الثنائيه مع روسيا
على راس الاولويات اعلن بوتين عن احتمال
تعاون عسكريا مع كوريا الشماليه رغم
العقوبات الدوليه
في اقصى شرق روسيا يتوقف قطار الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون مدشنا محطه
جديده في العلاقات بين موسكو
سريعا يلتقي كيم نظيره فلاديمير بوتين
تحيات حاره وارتياح مشترك لثغره في جدار
العزله الدوليه ثم جوله في قاعده
فوستوتشني لاطلاق الصواريخ الفضائيه قبل
ان يبدا الرئيسان اولى مباحثتهما في تناغم
يحاكي تناغم الوان على مي بلديهما وعندما
حان موعد مادبه العشاء الرسميه ازداد
اللقاء الفتى بين كيم وبوتين
نسعى جاهدين لتعزيز مسار الصداقه وحسن
الجوار ونعمل من اجل السلام والاستقرار
والازدهار في منطقتنا المشتركه
ساعمل مع الرئيس بوتين لبناء علاقات كوريه
روسيه مستقره وموجهه نحو المستقبل لفتره
طويله وتحويل العلاقات بيننا الى تعاون
استراتيجي متين
بعيدا عن الاضواء يرجح ان التعاون العسكري
استاثر بالمباحثات تحتاج للذخائر في حربها
على اوكرانيا بينما تتطلع الى تكنولوجيا
الاقمار الاصطناعيه بعد فشلها مرتين في
وضع قمر اصطناعي للتجسس العسكري في المدار
الرئيس الروسي نفسه لم يستبعد تعاونا من
ذاك القبيل مع كوريا الشماليه رغم
العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه على بلاده
بينما يتخوف الغرب من تاثر الحرب في
اوكرانيا بحصول الروس على اسلحه من كوريا
الشماليه وعليه استبق البيت الابيض زياره
رئيسها بالتحذير من انها ستدفع الثمن اذا
فعلت ذلك
مشاهدينا الكرام مستمرون معكم في هذه
التغطيه المباشره لتداعيات الفيضانات
واثار اعصار دانيال في ليبيا والزلزال في
المغرب ونبدا الساعه الثانيه من حصاد هذه
الليله بالعناوين
بعد احصائي اكثر من خمسه الاف قتيل جراء
كارثه السيول في الشرق الليبي تقديرات
بارتفاع عدد الضحايا مع وجود الاف
المفقودين وجهود انقاذ تتسارع خوفا من
انتشار الاوبئه وراسان المجلس الرئاسي
والحكومه حكومه الوحده يطلبان من النائب
العام فتحه تحقيق عاجلا في ملابسات انهيار
سدين
فرق الانقاذ في المغرب تكثف جهودها في قرى
معزوله قرب مركز الزلزال عمليات لفتح
مسالك جبليه مقطوعه لايصال المساعدات
للمناطق المنكوبه وعمليات الاغاثه تركز
على ايواء اللاجئين وعلاج المصابين
بعد يوم من اعلان اتفاق لوقف لاطلاق النار
سبعه قتله في اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله
والقذائف الصاروخيه في مخيم عين الحلو
للاجئين الفلسطينيين جنوبيه لبنان
[موسيقى]
البدايه مع تغطيتنا لتطورات السيول في
درنه الليبيه
[موسيقى]
ذكرت وكاله الانباء الليبيه ان عدد القتل
جراء السيول وصل الى 5000 وثلاثمائه بينما
يقدر عدد المفقودين بالالاف من جهه قال
مسؤول في الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر ان نحو عشره الاف
شخص هم في عداد المفقودين واظهرت صور
التقطت اليوم حجم الدمار الذي خلفته
السيول والفيضانات في مدينه درنه خصوصا
المناطق المتاخمه للوادي الذي يشق المدينه
والواجهه البحريه التي تاثرت كثيرا
بالسيول
قال رئيس مصلحه الطرق والجسور الليبيه
حسين سويدان ان الاعصار دانيال جرف كل
المباني السكنيه المجاوره لوادي درنه وان
ثلاثه ملايين متر مربع هي المساحه
المتضرره بشكل بالغ في مدينه درنه وقال
السويدان ان طول شبكه طرق المنهاره في
مدينه درنه يبلغ 30 كيلومترا مع انهيار
خمسه جسور تربط بين شرق مدينه درنه وغربها
وتظهر صور للاقمار الصناعيه حجم الدمار
الذي لحق بالمناطق السكنيه في درنه ويبدو
واضحا في الصور انهيار كام انهيار كامل
لاحد السدود مقارنه مع حالته قبل الطوفان
قال رئيس المجلس الرئاسي اللي بيه محمد
المنفي انه طلب من النائب العام فتحه
تحقيق شاملا في وقائع الفيضانات التي
اجتاحت مدينه درنه ومحاسبه كل من اخطا او
اهمل بالامتناع او بالقيام بافعال نجم
عنها انهيار سدي المدينه حسب تعبيره واكد
للنفي في منشور على منصه اكس ان
التحقيقاته ستشمل كل من قام بتعطيل جهود
الاغاثه الدوليه او عرقله وصولها الى
المدن المنكوبه من جهه قال رئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه عبد الحميد
الدبيبه انه خاطب المستشار المستشار
النائب العام لفتح تحقيق عاجل في ملابسات
الواقعه ووجه الاجهزه المعنيه بالتعاون
الكامل في ذلك
من طرابلس ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره احمد
خليفه احمد ما اخر المعلومات الوارده عن
تطورات الاوضاع في درب
الاوضاع كما هي عليه منذ يوم امس الركيزه
الاساسيه الان للاوضاع ال سي هناك هي
البحث عن المزيد من الجثث هذا هو المطلب
الوحيد في المدينه حاليا باعتبار ان اعداد
كبيره جدا من الجثث ما زالت مدفونه تحت
الركام ركام المنازل المهدمه وايضا في
البحر تحدثنا مع مصادرنا في وقت سابق من
في مدينه درنه وهم بالمناسبه اقارب لضحايا
لقوا حتفهم في هذه الفيضانات والسيول
ولديهم اقارب هنا في العاصمه طرابلس
وتحديدا في هذا العزاء الجماعي لضحايا
السيول الذي نقف فيه الان
حدثتنا المصادر ان هناك الالاف من الجثث
ما زالت تحت الركام وفي البحر ايضا
المصادر تحدثت معنا وقالت ان عمليه انتشال
الجثث ما زالت تتم بشكل بطيء وغير متسارع
وان مرور الوقت الان مره ثلاثه ايام على
هذه الكارثه وغدا هو اليوم الرابع
وبالتالي هناك تخوفات من ان التحلل الجثث
وتعفنها في تحت الركام قد يؤدي الى انتشار
الاوبئه والامراض ولعل هذا ما دعى مديريه
امن مدينه درنه الى الاعلان اليوم عن حظر
التجول في المدينه الى يوم الاثنين القادم
باعتبار ان هناك السكان الذين نجوا ولجاوا
الى مناطق اخرى الان رجعوا الى مساكنهم
يفتشون عن الجثث ويفتشون عن اقاربهم في
الممرات وفي المسارات التي فتحت داخل
الشوارع وتحت الركام وبالتالي هناك تخوفات
من انتشار الامراض والاوبئه جراء وجود هذه
الجثث بعد مرور 72 ساعه عليها
بعد هذه السيول الجارفه انقسمت الى نصفين
حقيقه هناك شق غربي وهناك شق شرقي الشق
الشرقي افضل حالا الى حد بعيد من الشق
الغربي المساعدات التي تاتي من المنطقه
الغربيه من المدن الواقعه غرب درنه تاتي
الى الشق الغربي في المدينه اما الشق
الشرقي فانه يعاني اوضاع انسانيه صعبه
وفق ما ذكرت لنا المصادر وبالتالي هناك
نقص في الادويه هناك نقص في امدادات
المياه
هناك نقص كبيره ايضا في امدادات الوقود
والاغذيه وبقيه المستلزمات المعيشيه
الاخرى حتى المساعدات المحليه وايضا
المساعدات الدوليه والاقليميه التي توجهت
الى مدينه درنه فانها غالبا تاتي الى الشق
الشرق الغربي من المدينه اليوم في حديثنا
مع مع وزير المواصلات بحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه
التقيناه مساء هذا اليوم في مطار
استقينا منه بعض المعلومات حول الوضع هناك
قال هناك الان مجهودات لمحاوله ربط الشقين
الغربي والشرقي في مدينه دردا بمعضهما
البعض عن طريق اقامه جسر للمشاه وايضا جسر
لتتحرك عبره الاليات ليسهل التنقل بين
الشقين في المدينه مما يسهل عمليه التواصل
لان حتى
شبكه التواصل او شبكه الاتصال تعاني ضعفا
رجعت الى مدينه درنه ولكنها تعاني ضعفا
الى حد كبير ايضا حتى شركه الكهرباء هناك
مجهودات لاعاده الكهرباء الى كامل مدينه
درنه عاده الكهرباء بعد انقطاع لمده يومين
تقريبا لكنها عادت بشكل تدريجي ولم تعد
كما كانت قبل هذه الكارثه اشكرك حتى
الساعه مراسلنا احمد خليفه من طرابلس
من طرابلس تنضموا الينا امل البرغوثي
مسؤوله التواصل والمناصره بمنظمه اليونيسف
في ليبيا مرحبا بك سيده امل البرغوثي ما
هو دوركم في هذه المرحله
كمنظمه يونيسف وعموم منظمات الامم المتحده
في اطار الجهود الجاريه في دارنا
السلام عليكم في البدايه ترحم على ضحايا
سيور الشرق الليبي بتر هذه العاصفه خاصه
في مناطق درنا البيضاء والمرج هي فعلا
فاجعه كارثه انسانيه ولها تداعيات كبيره
على الذين الاطفال بشكل خاص
اليوم سوف تعمل مع وكاله الام المتحده
الاخرى
عرض تنسيق الوثيق مع جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
اللي هو شاركنا على الارض استجابه للوضع
الانساني ايضا لجنه خليط الازمه بالشرق
والغرب ولجنه الطوارئ بالاضافه الى
التنسيق مع مكاتب التعاون الدولي في
الوزارات من خلال شركنا الهلال الاحمر
الليبي تقدم اليوسف المساعده في درنه
وغيرها من مناطق المتضرره من العاصفه من
خلال اخلاء العائلات تحديد طرق امنه
للخروج تقديم الاسعافات الاوليه في هذه
المداخل مداخل المدينه الدعم الطبي دعم
عمليات الانقاذ التي تقوم بها وتقودها
السلطات المحليه ايضا تقوم اليونس بتوزيع
مواد اغاثه ومواد اساسيه امتدادات طبيه
لحوالي عشره هل من ارقام واحصاءات لما
قدمتموه حتى الان
قدمنا حتى الان امدادات طبيه اساسيه
وايضا
حقائب النظافه الشخصيه لعشره الاف شخص
لمده ثلاثه اشهر
ملابس شتويه ايضا لعدد 500 من الاطفال
وايضا مجموعات نظافه الشخصيه اللي هو 1100
مجموعه طيب الان الجهود كلها منصبه على
جهود الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجين ولكن
ما هي الاولويات في المرحله المقبله بعد
الانتهاء من ذلك
ليبيا اولويات خلال الشهر القادم خلينا
نقولو اللي هي اولويات الحصول على الماوى
لان عندنا اكثر من 35 الف ناجح حسب تقارير
منظمه الهجره الدوليه
حصول هؤلاء النازحين على
مكان للسكن حصول على مياه شرب امنه ونظيفه
لذلك قامت اليونس بارسال 32 الف قرص كلور
لضمان مياه شرب امنه بسبب مخاطر التلوث
ايضا او من اولوياتنا هي تقديم خدمات
حمايه الطفل والاسره بشكل مباشر لدى
تقييمنا الوضع هناك العديد من الاطفال
النازحين قاعده عندهم صدمه فهم بحاجه الى
الدعم النفسي الاجتماعي فهذه تعتبر وايضا
الامدادات الطبيه بالفعل لان معظم
المستشفيات في دارنا هي عاطله عن العمل
كما تحدثتي سيده امل هناك
نحو 36 الف شخص بحسب
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده خرجوا من هذه المناطق التي تاثرت
بالسيول ما مصير هؤلاء اين يمكن ان يذهبوا
وماذا عن الماوى بالنسبه لهم
حتى الان لدينا ارقام بان عدد كبير 30 الف
نزحوا من درنه بالضبط عدد كبير
هم موجودون الان حاليا في في اماكن
عامه كالمدارس في 18 مدرسه في بنغازي حتى
الان تحوي حوالي الفين الى 3000 شخص نازح
بس احد الجهود
المبذوله الان من قبل النزف هي ايجاد ماوى
مؤقت لهؤلاء النازحين طيب سيده امل الان
هناك مخاوف كبيره من موضوع تكدس الجثث في
مدينه درنه ومخاوف من انتشار الاوبئه كيف
تتعاملون مع هذه المخاوف مع حجمها وما
خطورتها بالنسبه لكم
الان
كجزء من من
استجابه اليونيسف نحن ننظم
لتحضير لحمل التطعيم بالشراكه مع المركز
الوطني لمكافحه الامراض التابعه لوزاره
الصحه الليبيه هناك تطعيمات للاطفال من سن
الواحد لسن السته تطعيم ضد الحصبه وايضا
لدينا حمله مع المركز الوطني
لتقديم فيتامين اي لحوالي 12 الف طفل نازح
نتمنى هذه حلول تبدو وكانها حلول تستهدف
المدى البعيد ماذا عن الحلول الانيه حلول
المدى القصير والاني
الحلول المدى القصير كلها تعتمد على مدى
قدره فرق الانقاذ على الارض على انتشار
الجثث وايضا اخراج
الناس الاحياء من المدينه
الى الى مناطق تكون اكثر امان شكرا جزيلا
لك من طرابلس امل البرغوث مسؤوله التواصل
والمناصره بمنظمه اليونيسف في ليبيا
من تكنس جنوب مدينه المرج في شرق ليبيا
معنا خالد عيسى مدير مستشفى تاكنس سيد
خالد معنا
مرحبا بكم طيب مرحبا بك سيد خالد عيسى
ونسالك عن وضع مستشفى تاكنس من بعد ما حدث
هذه الكارثه التي حدثت وعموم المستشفيات
والقطاع الصحي في المنطقه
بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صفه الدكتور خالد محمد عيسى مدير مستشفى
العام في البدايه نشكر قناه ليبيا الاحرار
على التواصل المستمر معنا
وطبعا مدينه المناطق المتضرره نتيجه
العاصفه الدانيه وهي اول منطقه
نتضرر العديد من الاحياء وسقوط العديد من
المشاكل وذلك نتيجه غزاره الامطار وجريان
داوديه ولكن بفضل الله
العامه كانت السباق
والاليات العديد من
النسبه للمستشفى بالنسبه لنقص الاحتياجات
المستشفى
طبعا مستشفى ساكن في استقبلت
حوالي 50 حاله حاله اصابه
منها الانعاش والعنايه والطواري
ولكن الحمد لله الان بصحه جيده كذلك
استقبلنا 11 حاله وفاه
وكذلك كثره نعم ما نوع الاصابات الان التي
يتم التعامل معها على الارض
[موسيقى]
استقبلنا حالات
المخيلي حتى هي متضرره
كذلك المناطق المجاوره متضرره من بياضه
استقبلنا حالات كل مناطق متضرره
طبعا الكارثه اكبر درنه ولكن في مناطق
اخرى متبرره
يترددا علينا من المناطق المجاوره يعني
طيب كانت هناك من هذه المناطق كلها بضروره
المساعده فيما يتعلق بالمستلزمات الطبيه
على هذا المستوى كيف يمكن وصف الوضع حاليا
المشكله اللي واجهت مشكله الانقطاع
الاتصالات ما فيش اتصالات اثناء اثناء
سقوط الامطار يعني
ثلاثه ايام ما فيش اتصالات بين المناطق من
اي منطقه ما تعرفش المنطقه الاخرى
طبعا نحن نناشد رئيس الحكومه بالتدخل
السريع في توفير النقص من الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه والاجهزه والمعدات
الطبيه
مثلا اجهزه التقدير التنفس الصناعي حضانات
الاطفال
لدينا نقص شديد في هذه الاجهزه كذلك نجد
بتوفير مصنع اكس جين او خزان اكسجين
والسيوانات الاكسجين لدينا نقص شديد في في
كل هذه الاجهزه والمعدات الطبيه ماذا عن
وضع الكهرباء ومياه الشرب ايضا وهذه كلها
تؤثر على عمل القطاع الصحي
نعم نعم
نحن نحن في المناطق
والمدن
لما تنقطع الكهرباء
الخبزه تنقطع المياه تنقطع كلا كل شبه
الحياه اليوميه يعني توقف السبل الحيه
وايضا ازمه ومشكله التكدس الجثث سيد خالد
انتم في القطاع الصحي في مستشفى تاكنس
تحديدا
ما حجم هذه المشكله لديكم وما الحلول
المقترحه
في مدينه درنه الكثير من يعني حوالي الان
يقال ان محاوله
10,000 يعني الحال
وما الحلول ما المطلوب حاليا من اجل حل
هذه الازمه
تكاثف الجهود من القياده العامه من
الاجهزه الامنيه من خلال الاحمر الان كلهم
موجودين في في مدينه درنا الان في نقل هذه
خالد عيسى مدير مستشفى تاكنس من جنوب
مدينه المرج في شرق ليبيا شكرا لك
لاعبات الجغرافيا دورا في تعظيم حجم
الدوار في مدينه درنه شرقيه ليبيا موقعها
المنخفض عند شاطئ المتوسط ووادي درنه الذي
يقطعها والنهر الذي يمر بها وغزاره
الامطار شكلت عوامل اساسيه في جرف احياء
بكاملها الى البحر وبلغت مساحه الدمار
قرابه عشره كيلومترات مربعه في المدينه
التفاصيل نتابعها في التقرير التالي
غلبت الجغرافيا كل الاحتمالات في ليبيا
وكما ان للزلزال من مركز باتت مدينه درنه
نقطه تركز الفاجعه تقع دارنا على ضفاف واد
كبير يعرف باسم وادي درنه يتجاوز طوله 60
كيلومترا ومساحه حوض التجميع فيه تبلغ
570 كيلومترا مربعا تقريبا
تقسم درنا الى مجموعه من الاحياء المنخفضه
التي تتشكل من مساحه واسعه تطل على البحر
المتوسط وابرزها وسط المدينه او المدينه
القديمه تتركز فيها اغلب المصارف
والمؤسسات الحكوميه والمقر الاداريه
والاسواق التجاريه وهي الاكثر تضررا من
السيول التي جرفت الابديه ومنازل المدينه
القديمه والقت بها في البحر
زحفت اليها المياه بعد انهيار السدين في
درنه ووصل ارتفاع المياه ما بين سته امتار
وسبعه
حي الجبيله غرب المدينه جرفه السيد
بالكامل وحي المغار جنوب المدينه لحقه
الضرر بشكل واسع
وهناك احياء المدينه المرتفعه حي شيح
الغربي حي الشرقيه حي باب طبرق حي الساحل
الشرقي
تغير وجه المدينه بفعل العاصفه والطوفان
حيث تقدر المساحه التي تعرضت لتدمير
بقرابه عشره كيلومترات مربعه وبحسب خبراء
فان الضرر الهائل نتج عن عاملين اساسيين
كميه الامطار التي بلغت 200 ملم في يوم
واحد اي قرابه 200 لتر لكل متر مربع في
اقل من 24 ساعه
مقابل 200 مليمتر تسقط خلال عام كامل على
درنه هذه الكميات ادت الى تراكم 115 مليون
متر مكعب من المياه في وادي درنه
ولتقريب التقدير فان اي خزان منزلي للمياه
تبلغ سعته مترا مكعبا واحدا بمعنى ان
المياه التي حبست في الوادي تعادل 115
مليون خزان منزلي يضاف اليها قوه التدفق
الهائله والطم والحجاره التي سحبتها معها
ما رفع من قدره المياه التدميريه كما ان
انهيار السدين كان عاملا حاسما في تعظيم
قدره السيل على التدمير سد منصور يقع على
بعد 13 كيلومترا بسعه تخزينيه تقدر بنحو
ثلاثه وعشرين مليون مكعب سد البلاد الذي
يقع على بعد كيلو متر واحد من المدينه
بسعه تخزينيه تصل لمليون ونصف المليون متر
مكعب فقد السدان قدرتهما الاستيعابيه
وانفجر بشكل كامل
شيدت هذه السدود لحمايه المدينه من جريان
وادي درنه عام 2002 حذرت دراسه من ان سدود
درنه تشكل تهديدا محتملا رغم ذلك بقيت دون
اي صيانه
ليرتفع عدد الضحايا جراء هذه العوامل
مجتمعه الى الالاف بين قتيل ومفقود
من تونس سينضم الينا احمد بيرم المستشار
الاعلامي للمجلس النرويجي للاجئين بمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط مرحبا بك سيد احمد بيرم ما
هي تقديراتكم بشان اخطر التداعيات التي
يمكن ان تنجم عن هذه الكارثه التي ضربت
الشرق الليبي ولا سيما درنه
مساء الخير
اخطر تداعيات هي بالتاكيد حاليا يعني كلمه
الجهود عم تتركز على اجلاء الضحايا على
اخراج الجثه مثل ما ذكرت في حضرتك
بمكونات السابقه مع ساده الفضلاء يعني
اخراج الجثث او حتى وضعها في اكياس بعمليه
معقده حاليا بسبب نقص الموارد وبسبب نقص
الطاقات على الارض
اكيد عاملين طوارئ يعملون خلال 24 ساعه
لحتى
يطلعوا الناس من تحت من تحت الدمار
فانتشار الاوبئه انتشار الامراض هو بحاله
يمكن نشوفها وشفنا هذا الشيء بكتير سياق
صراعات من قبل بمناطق في الشرق الاوسط في
مناطق الصراعات في سوريا في اليمن وفي
مناطق اخرى الحاله الثانيه هي حاله النزوح
يلي عم بيكون
عم بيتراكم
امامنا حاليا في حوالي
60 الف في تقارير عم تحكي عن ستين الف
نازح ممكن يكون عم يخرج
طبعا راح يكون بحاجه لمقوى راح يكونوا
بحاجه لطعام راح يكونوا بحاجه لمياه
امكانيه ايجاد ماوى لهم وما امكانيه ايضا
عودتهم الى المدينه في ظل محل بها
حاليا يعني راح يكون كثير صعب يعني شفنا
صور الدمار وبعتقد وقتها راح يكون راح
نوقف على الحجم حجم
حجم اوضح للخسائر راح يكون عم يتبين مع
انه في ناس كتير مش راح تقدر ترجع على
بيوتها للاسف راح يكون عم يضطروا يعيشوا
في ماوى مؤقت وهذا مؤقت الشيء يعني يمكن
سنين
في مناطق يمكن تكون بعيده عن ديارهم ولكن
بنفس الوقت هذا الشيء بحاجه لتمويل تمويل
هائل من المجتمع الدولي اللي عم نعيدها
لحتى يتضافر لحتى يحط السياسه على جنب
ويكون عم بيقدم المساعده في ناس عم تخبرنا
انه ثلاثه ايام مش عم تنام ما عندها اثنين
في حتى الاطفال اللي عم بيعيشوه هلا
والجسس اللي عم بيشوفوها ملكات على يعني
على الارض ما في حدا عم يقدر ينتشلها هذا
الشيء راح يخلق كمان حاله نفسيه كتير صعبه
للايام والشهور اللي جايه كل هذه الازمه
بهذه الابعاد المتعدده ما هي انعكاساتها
على المدى الطويل على
البلاد عموما من وجهه نظركم يعني
للاسف مع نقص التمويل اللي شفناه بالسنوات
الاخيره ليبيا كانت خارج الاجنده العالميه
للتمويل خارج جوده القوى الكبرى للتمويل
المبولين للكبار يعني للاسف عم نشوف
تداعياتها مش مش من ثلاثه ايام ثلاثه سنين
نقص التمويل عم يؤدي الى زياده حالات
الفقر
لعدم قدره الناس على التعافي وهذا الشيء
كمان راح يكون بوضع سواء من بعض من بعض
الكرسي الاطفال خارج المدارس الفتيات
والسيدات اللي للاسف عم بيكونوا في خطر
حمايه هذا الشيء راح ينعكس على الجيل اللي
عم بعيش هلا فيه ليبيا يلي كان صراع الى
حد ما وكان عم بيجرب يتعافى للاسف هاي ضرب
اسيا راح تكون لالهم راح ترجعهم سنين لورا
لذلك عم ندعي مباشره ومن دون اي تاجيل او
تلكك او حتى حسابات سياسيه يكونوا
الممولين عم يجتمعوا على ويقدموا اكثر
يعني ادمه مساعده اللي شفناها حتى
كوارث اخرى ليست ببعيده اشكرك احمد بيرم
المستشار والاعلامي للمجلس النرويجي
للاجئين بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط ضيفنا من
تونس
وصلت الى مطار بنينا في بنغازي طائرات
مساعدات قطريه وعلى متنهما فرق من الهلال
الاحمر القطري وفريق اغاثه وانقاذ من قوه
الخويا كما ارسلت قطر مستشفى ميدانيا يضم
160 سريرا ومعدات بحث وفرق انقاذ مع اقامه
جسر جوي للدعم يتضمن مساعدات غذائيه وطبيه
وتتوالى المساعدات ايضا من دول عربيه اخرى
لمواجهه تداعيات الماساه الانسانيه في
درنه فقد سير الاردن طائرات اغاثه عسكريه
الى ليبيا تحمل على متنها اطنانا من مواد
الاغاثه والمستلزمات الانسانيه ومن مصر
اقلعت ثلاث طائرات نقل عسكريه الى ليبيا
وحمل بكميات كبيره من الادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه بالاضافه بالاضافه الى اعداد كبيره
من الخيام وطواقم للبحث والانقاذ ومجموعات
عمل من الهلال الاحمر
معنا من بنغازي توفيق الشكري المتحدث
الرسمي باسم جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الليبي
مرحبا بك سيد توفيق الشكري قربنا اكثر من
ما يجري على الارض في درنه وعموم المناطق
التي تاثرت بهذه الفيضانات كيف تبدو
عمليات البحث والانقاذ حاليا
ما زالت فرق الهلال الاحمر الليبي
بالاضافه الى الفلق المختصه من الحكومه
الليبيه وكذلك
المسلحه وفي اضافه الى الفرق
الاقليميه والدوليه
تعمل في الميدان في مدينه درنه ولكن حجم
كبير جدا فوقها
[موسيقى]
الجاريه عمليه البحث حسب الاحصائيات
المتواجده لدينا اكثر من عشره
مفقود
جاري عمليه
الانقراض
وكذلك انتشار جثث من تحت الرقام
سي
توفيق في هذه المرحله
من المتوقع ان يكون هناك نجيم تحت الانقاذ
العمليات مستمره
والعثور على على هؤلاء المقصودين كل ساعه
وكل دقيقه نتاخر فيها بعمليه البحث ودعم
جهود البحث
يتحول عدد المفقودين الى عدد ضحايا ما
الصعوبات التي تواجه العمليات عمليات
البحث والانقاذ على الارض حاليا
من ابرز التحديات ان
المفقودين اعتبروا
تحت العقاب جزء اخر
بالمياه البحر ومنذ الصعوبات والتحديات
البحر يمكن التيار داخل
الانترني بالجثث الى ابعد اماكن من منطقه
او مدينه درنه في هذه الحاله تكون طلقات
تبحث في مكان وهو ليس مكانه صحيحه
التعبير وماذا عن الجثث المتكدسه حاليا في
قلب المدينه والتي يخشى ان تكون سببا
لانتشار الامراض والاوبئه بسبب ازمه دفن
هذه الجثث وازمه عدم توفر برادات لحفظها
ماذا عن هذا الجانب
تتعامل سلطات وكذلك الهلال الاحمر ليبيا
على الفور مع الجثثله
بالتعرف على هؤلاء
ضحايا ومن ثم يتم دفع من يتعرف عليهم
بطبيعه الحال المدينه يقبلها سكانها من
الليبيين
بالاضافه الى
العماله الوافيه التي من الممكن صعب
التعرف عليهم في الايام الاولى ولكن مكتب
الهلال الاحمر والفرق الهلال الاحمر في
درنه والمناطق المتضرره تعمل عليه مساله
فتح الملفات للمفقدين
وتسجيل
عبر العلامات الداله
لهؤلاء المسؤولين
فان فرص العثور على احياء ما زالت موجوده
مع استمرار عمليات البحث ماذا عن
تقديراتكم بشان هذه العمليات متى يمكن ان
تنتهي عمليا بالنظر الى حجم ما حدث
اصعب التكهم بمساله الوقت سواء كانت
انتهاء العمليات او وصول الى احياء وناجين
في هذه العمليه عمليه الانقاذ ولكن كلما
كانت الفرقه موجوده بزياد كبيره وكل ما
ساهمت المنظمات وكذلك الدول بتوفير
المعدات للفرق المحليه يسهل علينا العمل
وتكون لدينا السرعه في الوصول الى هؤلاء
المفقودين سواء كانوا ضحايا ام نجيم ما هي
ما نوع المعدات المطلوبه حاليا وانت يعني
تناشد الدول بتقديمها
في الاماكن التي توجد بها دمار يحتاج الى
سيارات من الدوره الدفع رباعي وخيارات
مخصصه
للانتشاك بالاضافه الى الاكياس فحفظ
الجفامين
مطلوبه بدرجه كبيره لجمعيه الاحمر كذلك
الزوارق المطاطيه في البحر
وكذا عمليه البحث عن طريق الطائره طيب سيد
سيد توفيق ماذا عن موضوع البنيه التحتيه
الصحيه وكانت هناك مناشدات من داخل
المدينه خلال ساعات النهار بضروره
المساعده في المستلزمات الطبيه وفي توفير
الكهرباء ومياه الشرب ايضا ماذا عن هذا
الجانب
صحيح
ولكن المنطقه
بالعام
التي تعرضت للسيول الفيضانات لدينا مستشفى
البيضاء مستشفى قرينه في في مدينه سحاب
بامكان دعم هذه المستشفيات وتجهيزها كامل
واعاده الحياه فيها ان كان تكون قريبه الى
مدينه درنه ونقل الحياه والاصابات الى هذه
المستشفيات
شكرا جزيلا لك من بنغازي توفيق الشكر
المتحدث الرسمي باسم جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الليبي
من طرابلس ينضم الينا فتح الله زني وزير
الشباب في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه ونائب
رئيس الفريق الحكومي للطوارئ والاستجابه
السريعه مرحبا بك سيد فتح الله تقييمكم في
هذه المرحله لعمليات البحث والانقاذ
الجاريه في المناطق التي نكبت بالسيول
مساء الخير
نشكركم نشكر القناه الجزيره على هذه
المواكبه لتغطيه
الفاجعه لحلت بالمناطق الشرقيه في ليبيا
على ايش الخصوص مدينه درنه الحقيقه تقريبا
كل القطاعات الدوله المعنيه
من الاسعاف والطوارئ
والمصلحه الطرق والجسور المواصلات المباحث
الجنائيه
السلام الوطنيه كل الفرق هذه الاجهزه
انتقلت الى المناطق الشرقيه
ودخلت لمدينه درنه اللي كان خلال اليومين
الماضيين في صعوبه لدخول للمدينه لكن بعد
فتح مسارات الترابيه كل الان ايضا حتى
شركات
الخدمات العامه تتواجد في المدينه لان منذ
يوم الامس
كل هذه الاجهزه استلمت مواقعها وتنسق مع
الادارات المحليه
ومع الاجهزه الصحيه وبدات اعمالها بالفعل
في عمليات
كل الفرق العامله على الارض تشكو من ضعف
الامكانات من غياب المعدات اللازمه من اجل
المساعده في تسريع هذه العمليات عمليات
الانقاذ الجاريه على الارض من يتحمل
مسؤوليه هذا الانعدام الكبير في
البنيه التحتيه لمثل هكذا عمليات
وبالفعل اولا لان طبيعه الجغرافيا داخل
المدينه المدينه
انقسمت جراء الفيضان الانسداد
الجراء
الفيضانات وانهيار سد وجدرنا وسد وابو
منصور في المدينه انقسمت الى الشق الغربي
والشقه الشرقي هو ما كانش امكانيه خلال 48
الساعه الماضيه قبل 48 ساعه الماضيه لدخول
المدينه من مسار محدود للطرق لان الطرق
الرئيسيه الثلاثه انقطعت لكن كانت فيه
صعوبه لكن من اليوم الحقيقه في النتائج
لاعمال الفرق واللجان واصبحت فيه تزويد
يعني اليوم مستشفى درنه فيه اثنين
مستشفيات ميدانيه في باب طبرق وفي شيحه
استلمت مواقعها من جهاز الطب الطوارئ
الان الفرق اللي هي خاصه بفتح المسارات
الترابيه من مصلحه الطرق
هذين الميدانيين كافيين للتعامل مع حجم
هذه الكارثه وماذا ايضا نعم تفضل هو في
الحقيقه في الحقيقه نتكلموا عليه مدينه
درنه المنطقه الشرقيه بالكامل المنطقه
الممتده من المرج غرب غربا الى
ام الرزم
وشرق مدينه درنه نتكلموا على تقريبا 12
قريه ومدينه حل بها هذا العصار العمليات
الكبرى هي تجرى داخل مدينه درنه
ومدينه سوسه بتيجي في المرتبه الثانيه
احنا نتكلم الان على الجهود التي تبدا
المختلف قطاعات اليوم المباحث الجنائيه
النيابه العموميه
باشرت اعمالها تقريبا من من 48 ساعه في
عمليات الاذن
الدفن ونقل المصابين ايضا هناك عمليه
الايواء الاغاثه والدعم النفسي والاسناد
وتوزيع المساعدات كل كل هذه الاجهزه الان
موجوده تباعا اتباعا الحقيقه
تم تحسن كبير جدا على مستوى الميدان لهذه
العمليه شكرا لك فتح الله الزني وزير
الشباب في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه ونائب
رئيس الفريق الحكومي لطوارئ والاستجابه
السريعه من طراب
الى مصر حيث شيعت جسامين عشرات العمال
المصريين الذين قضوا في السيول والفيضانات
التي اجتاحت مدينه درنا الليبيه جراء
الاعصار دانيال وينتمي القتل الى قريه
الشريف في محافظه بني سويف ومعظمهم اقرباء
وقد تم تشييعهم ودفنهم في مقابر اسرهم وسط
حضور كبير ولا تزال هناك اعداد من
المصريين في عداد المفقودين فيما يواصل
الاهالي اطلاق النداءات لاعاده جسميني
بقيه الضحايا المصريين
الاربعه
الصالحين
وعل نادي على النساء
جمال عبد الوهاب بنزال
وروحنا جمال عبد الوهاب بنساوي الاربعه
اخر مره كلمني ياسر يوم بس هو
كلم يوم الخميس اللي فات ده كان اخر مره
قال له ده اجيب لبس للعيال وانزه لنفسه
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب والمشهد في ختام اليوم مع
اقتراب الزلزال من اكمال يومه الخامس
[موسيقى]
تواصل فرق الانقاذ جهودها للوصول الى
احياء تحت الركام في المناطق المتضرره من
زلزال الجمعه الماضي كما تستمر العمليات
الراميه لفتح الطرق الجبليه المؤديه الى
القرى النائيه وسط مخاوف من انهيارات
صخريه جديده وتركز فرق الانقاذ جهودها
لانقاذي واجلاء الجرحى وتكفل بالمتضررين
الذين فقدوا الماوى وقد افادت وزاره
الداخليه بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى
296 والمصابين الى 567
من اشبيليه في اسبانيا تنضم الينا كرستن
صدرلاند منسقه البرنامج الانساني في منظمه
اكشن ايد اسبانيا سيده
كيف تتابعون عمليات انتشال الضحايا ورفع
الركام ومحاوله العثور على ناجين حتى
الساعه في المغرب
منظمتي اكشن
خرطت في العمل منذ عشرين عاما في المغرب
ولدينا شراكات مع منظمات في المغرب ونحن
نشجع على العمل مع الشركاء ولذلك نلصق
معهم لكي نعرف ماهيه الاوضاع في الميدان
لدينا فريق من ثمانيه اشخاص في مراكش
ويزورون المجتمعات المختلفه بهدف تقييمي
الاحتياجات المختلفه في المغرب لكي نتمكن
من الاستجابه ايذاء هذه الكارثه الفظيعه
وما هي تقييمات الاوليه لهذا الفريق
نعرفه حتى اللحظه الراهنه اننا نتحدث حتى
300 الف شخص تاثروا بهذا الزلزال 30 الف
في حدود 15 كيلومتر يسكنون في حدود 10 او
قطر 15 كيلومتر من مركز الزلزال وذلك بناء
على التقرير الذي حصلنا عليه من زملائنا
في المغرب وهناك طبعا احتياجات مرتبطه
بالماوى والماكل والمشرب وبالاضافه الى
ذلك سوف نقدم المساعدات من حيث الدعم
الاجتماعي بالاضافه الى الاحتياجات بعيده
المدى والتزام اكشن
باعاده الناس الى حياتهم التي دمرت بسبب
هذا الزلزال
سبق وذكرت منظمتي تعمل في المغرب منذ 20
عاما وبالتالي لدينا شركات مع المنظمات
المختلفه لدينا وجود في البلاد والعلاقه
مع شركاء في المغرب قائمه اصلا
ولدينا الرغبه بالاستجابه ازاء هذه
الكارثه وهذا ليس بالامر الجديد نحن في
البلاد منذ فتره طويله وهو من بين
الالتزامات بالنسبه الينا كمنظمه انسانيه
وبني الواجبات التي نطلع بها وسوف نقدم
المساعدات من حيث الاحتياجات الاساسيه
للمجتمعات التي تاثرت بشكل فوري على الامد
الابعد سوف ننظر في احتياجات المرتبطه
بالماوى خصوصا وانا فصل الشتاء يقترب
والبرد القارس
يقترباوي الحاليه هي مؤقته وقد لا تكون
جاهزه وفيها الخصائص المطلوبه لحمايه
الناس من الحراره المنخفضه سوف نحاول ايضا
ان نعمل على مساعده
النساء والفتيات في خلال الازمات الاخرى
نعرف ان النساء والفتيات يتاثرن بشكل اكبر
في الازمات الانسانيه
وهذا بناء على ما حصل في ظروفا مختلفه في
اماكن مختلفه سوف ندعم الناس لكي يعودوا
الى حياتهم اليوم شكرا لك
مناسقه البرامج الانسانيه في منظمه اكشن
ايد الانسانيه الدوليه حدثنا من اشبيليه
في اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
في جنوب لبنان افادت مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه
بسقوط سبعه قتلى واربعه وعشرين جريحا في
اشتباكات بمخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين اليوم بين عناصر من حركه فتح
ومجموعه تطلق على نفسها اسم الشباب المسلم
وجاء تجدد الاشتباكات بعد هدوء نسبيا شهده
المخيم خلال الساعات الماضيه تخللته بعض
الخروق بين الحين والاخر كما ياتي بعد
اتفاق بين قيادتي حركتي فتح وحماس في
بيروت على المضي قدما بقرار هيئه العمل
الفلسطيني المشترك بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق
النار في المخيم وتسليم المتهمين باغتيال
قائد قوات الامن الوطني الفلسطيني ابو
اشرف العرموشي نهايه يوليو الماضي الى
السلطات اللبنانيه
من محيط مخيم عين الحلو في صيدا ينضم
الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره في بيروت مازن
ابراهيم مازن هل مازال القصف مستمرا
نعم في الواقع الان وانت تطرحين السؤال
نسمع في الخلفيه اطلاق الرصاص واطلاق بعض
القنابل والقذائف ضمن الازقه زقه مخيم عين
الحلوه صحيح ان هذا هذه الوتيره قد تراجعت
مقارنه بما كنا نشهده خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولكن رغم تراجع وتيره هذه
الاشتباكات لا شيء ينبئ باننا ذاهبون نحو
تسويه او حل او ايجاد مخرج لهذه المواجهات
التي تجددت منذ نحو سبعه ايام وكانت قد
وكنا قد شهدنا خلال الشهر الماضي ايضا
جوله اولى منها وادت الى مقتل واصابه
العشرات تتحدث عن 27 قتيلا ومئتي جريح
ارسل لماذا الامور لا تذهب الى تسويه
محتمله خلال الساعات المقبله لاننا ازاء
معادله مقفله بمعنى ان حركه فتح ورغم انها
وقعت اتفاقا مع حركه حماس
بضروره تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار ولكنها تصر
على ان يقوم من يوصفون بانهم من الشباب
المسلمين او تحديدا الشباب المسلم بتسليم
المتهمين باغتيال قائد الامن الوطني
الفلسطيني ابو اشرف العرموشي في صيدا ولكن
في المقابل الطرف الاخر وهم يسمون بالشباب
المسلمين وهم من
مسلحين كانوا ينتمون الى جندي الشام
وينتمون الى فصائل اسلاميه اخرى لاسيما
فتح الاسلام هم حتى هذه اللحظه يرفضون هذا
الامر نحن نتحدث عن ثمانيه مطلوبين قتل
احدهم خلال هذه الاشتباكات ويجي الان
الحديث عن سبعه مطلوبين فتح تصر على تسليم
هؤلاء ايضا هيئه العمل الفلسطيني المشترك
كانت قد توافقت بكامل فصائلها على ان تسعى
لتسليم هؤلاء ولكن الاشكاليه الان كيف
السبيل الى اقناع هؤلاء الذين تحصلون ضمن
مربعات امنيه بقيام بهذا الامر وهذا الامر
تحديد ومستبعد من قبل المسلحين الذين
يتواجهون حاليا يقاتلون في مواجهه حركه
فتح وبالتالي الاشتباكات تتراجع وتشتد بين
الفتره والاخرى ولكن ليس هنالك من مخرج
واضح لكيفيه تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
والشروع بالفعل في تسليم المطلوبين
باغتيال ابو اشرف عرموشي لذلك بعجله يمكن
القول ان المرحله المقبله الساعات والايام
المقبله قد تشهد مزيدا من الاشتباكات من
جهه ومزيد من المساعي والجهود لمحاوله
التوصل الى مخرج يجنب ليس فقط مخيم عين
حلوه ولكن ايضا مدينه صيدا كل هذا
السير من الدماء الذي شهدناه خلال الايام
والاسابيع الماضيه شكرا جزيلا لك مدير
المكتب الجزيره في بيروت مازن ابراهيم
حدثتها من محيطي مخيم عين الحلوه في صيدا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت بعثه الامم المتحده في السودان انها
تلقت انباء موثوقه عن وجود ما لا يقل عن
ثلاثه عشره مقبره جماعيه في مدينه الجنينه
ومحيطها في اقصى غرب السودان وذكرت البعثه
ان المقابر هي نتيجه هجمات قوات الدعم
السريع وميليشيات عربيه على مدنيين معظمهم
من قبيله المساليد وهم من غير العرب
ويمثلون اكبر تجمع سكاني في الجنينه وقالت
البعثه انها تعمل مع مسؤولين في الامم
المتحده على توثيق هذه الانتهاكات واذا تم
التحقق منها فقد تشكل ما وصفتها بجرائم
حرب
التقى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
العاصمه انقره رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقالت الدائره الاتصال
في الرئاسه التركيه ان الطرفين عقد
اجتماعا مغلقا لكن وزير الخارجيه التركيه
كان فيدان اوضح في مؤتمر صحفي عند سؤاله
عن مجريات اللقاء ان الرئيس اردوغان بحث
مع البرهان اليات ارسال الدعم الانساني
للسودان وجهود بلاده المستمره لايجاد حل
للازمه هناك ورافق البرهان في الزياره كل
من وزير الخارجيه المكلف عن الصادق ومدير
المخابرات العامه وقال الصادق لدى عوده
الوفد السوداني الى بلاده ان المباحثات
بين اردوغان والبرهان تطرقت للعلاقات
الثنائيه والتعاون الاقتصادي مضيفا ان
الجانب التركي اكد استعداده للمساعده في
اعمار ما دمته الحرب
قال
مبعوث الامين العام للامم المتحده الى
السودان انه طلب من الامين العام للمنظمه
الدوليه اعفائه من منصبه في هذه الاثناء
نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مصدر طبي
سوداني ان 40 شخصا قتلوا في غاره جويه
استهدفت سوقين شعبيين وعده احياء في مدينه
نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور غربيه
السودان
ليس امام الامين العام المتحده الا
الاستجابه لطلب السودان وتغيير هذا
المبعوث لن يتعامل معه انا انا لو كنت
مكان السيد فولكر سوف اقدم استقلت وقد كان
لكن وهو يعلن تنحيه عن منصبه اثر فولكر
رسم المشهد السوداني كما بداله
ليس هناك شك في المسؤول عن ما يجري في
كثير من الاحيان ينفذ القصف الجوي
العشوائي من قبل اولئك الذين لديهم قوه
جويه وهي القوات المسلحه السودانيه تحدث
معظم اعمال العنف الجنسي والنهب والقتل في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم
السريع يقوم كلا الجانبين بالاعتقال
التعسفي والاحتجاز وحتى تعذيب المدنيين
وهناك تقارير عن عمليات قتل خارج نطاق
القضاء ذاك تقرير مهمه انتهت ولعلها طوت
معها ازمه الموفد الاممي الخاص
مع سلطات الخرطوم التي صنفته شخصا غير
مرغوب فيه ايا يكن الامر فان الدبلوماسيه
الالماني ما زال يخشى من تحول نزاع
السودان كما يقول الى حرب اهليه
هل الى ذلك تسير الاحداث بالبلاد حقه
الواضح من تطورات الصراع المسلح انه لا
يفتا يحتدم في مدن العاصمه القوميه الثلاث
ولا تخف معه حده موجات الاقتتال الممتده
الى اقليم دارفور بغربي البلاد
مشاهد الحرب هنا وهناك تفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه لملايين هم خارجه حسابات
الاطراف المتقاتله
ليست حسابات الحروب كلها عسكريه فهذا قائد
الجيش ورئيس مجلس السياده السوداني يكثف
جولاته الخارجيه
الى مركز لحكمه ونشاطه
منها انطلق عبد الفتاح البرهان الى
القاهره فجبا فاسمر فالدوحه ثم اخيرا
انقره التي سبق وابدت استعدادها لاستضافه
مفاوضات شامله لانهاء الصراع الدائري في
السودان لكن ايا من طرفي الصراع هناك لم
يرد بعد بشكل رسمي على العرض التركي
من باريس ينضم الينا محمد تورشن الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك سيد
محمد لو بدانا بما اعلنت عنه بعثه الامم
المتحده في السودان اليوم عن العثور على
ثلاثه عشره مقبره جماعيه في مدينه الجنينه
بنتيجه هجمات لقوات الدعم السريع باعتقادك
اي انعكاسات لهذا التطور على مجمل ما يحصل
في السودان
هو بلا شك كل ما تمضي الايام يوم بعد يوم
تتكشف الكثير من الجرائم والانتهاكات التي
ارتكبتها قوات الدعم السريع ايذاء
المدنيين في الاخص في دارفور باعتبار ان
كل الاعلام وكذلك وسائل الاتصال المتوفر
في العاصمه الخرطوم وانا في تقدير هذه
المقابر التي اكتشفتها مؤخرا البعثه
الامويه في السودان
ربما في مقبره الايام يتم اكتشاف اكبر قدر
ممكن من المغابر باعتبار تحدثنا عن عدد
كبير جدا من اللاجئين الذين عبروا الحدود
الى جاد اتحدث عن فظائف تحدثوا عن هنالك
العشرات من المداريين يتم قتلهم ودفنهم في
مقابل الجماعيه حتى يتم بشكلها باخر اخفاء
المعالم او الجرائم التي ارتكبتها قوات
الدعم السريعه انا في تقدير الان ينبغي
على الامم المتحده وكذلك مجلس الامن
الدولي بالتعاون مع البيئه السودانيه في
نيويوركا بان يتم احاله هذا الملف الى
المحكمه الجنائي الدوليه ارسال خبراء
للتحقيق باعتبار ان كل ما طالت المده ربما
هنالك بعض المغابر يتم
اخفاء معالمها وكذلك تجاوز هذه الازمه
ربما عندما تكون هنالك تسويه ما الى ذلك
انا في تقديري هنالك ايضا جرائم وقعت في
وسط دارفور فيزا وكذلك في ولايه جنوب
دارفور في نياله فضلا عن الجرائم التي تقع
في الخرطوم ولايه
تقييمك للزياره التي قام بها اليوم
البرهان الى تركيا في هذا الاطار
هو بلا شك زياره عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس
مجلس السياده الى عدد من الدول هي بلا شك
ترسم واقع جديد او توجهات جديده للسياسه
الخارجيه السودانيه لاسيما بان التوجهات
منذ مشاركه السودان في عاصفه الحزم كانت
مرتبطه ارتباط وثيق محور الخليجي لاسيما
من محور المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكذلك
الامارات العربيه المتحده لكن الان سرعان
انا ما في تقدير تغيرت هذه التوجهات
وراينا هذه التوجهات عندما ذهب الى مصر
وذهب الى قطر وكذلك بجوار السودان كارتريا
او جنوب السودان والان توجه الى
العاصمه التركيه انقره ولا استبعد ان تحدث
مفاجاه كبيره وتحولات كبيره في السياسه
الخارجيه السودانيه عندما يزور بزياره
ربما غير معلنه او مفاجاه السيد عبد
الفتاح البرهان العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
لماذا لان الحرب ربما الجانب العسكري بدا
يستشعر بانها ستاخذ وقت
باعتقادك وتركيا تتحدث منذ بدايه الازمه
على انها مستعده للوساطه لماذا تركيا في
هذه المرحله تحديدا
الاعتبار الاول الجانب السوداني مرحب
بواسطه تركيا لكن في الجانب الاخر قوات
الدعم السريع لا اعتقد انها توافق
تركيا باي حال من الاحوال هنالك ايضا محور
مهم جدا وهو السودان بحاجه الى الى تسليح
بالرغم من ان السوداني يمتلك قدره من
انتاج بعض الاسلحه والزخائر لكن بحاجه الى
تقنيات قتاليه مهمه جدا لا سيما في مجال
قطاع الطيران
ومعلومه طائره التركيه بين اقدار لديها
قدرات وامكانيات اذا تم استخدامها الى
السودان يمكن ان تحقق فارق في ميزات
الكاتب والبحث السياسيه السوداني ضيفنا من
باريس
مشاهدينا بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام
حصاد هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم ولكن
التغطيه مستمره على راس الساعه ويرافقكم
فيها الزميل حسن